Today, we're going to talk about
reconstructing evolutionary trees.
And the way that we're going to begin is
with a story that may not seem
connected to evolutionary trees.
This looks like a pretty typical hotel,
but
it's actually the site of an important
moment in 21st Century history.
It's in Hong Kong, and
it used to be called the Metropole Hotel.
A Chinese doctor checked in to room 911
of this hotel on February 21, 2003.
He had been treating patients in
a rural area of mainland China,
who were suffering from
a deadly respiratory illness,
and he had come to Hong Kong for
a wedding the next day.
But when the next day came around,
he was too sick to attend, and
he wound up checking himself into
a hospital down the street from the hotel.
Two weeks later, he was dead.
Now you're probably wondering,
"Why on earth would I tell this sad story?"
So let me travel back in time to the
14th Century when the Black Death
killed a third of all Europeans.
The Black Death was lethal,
but it was also very slow.
It took four years for the Black Death
to travel from Constantinople
(or modern day Istanbul) to Kiev.
These days, you could do that trip by car
in just a day or just two hours by plane.
In the 21st Century though, all it
takes for a disease to go global and
become a crisis on the world scale is for
one person to travel from a an isolated
place in rural China to a business
hotel in densely populated Hong Kong.
Just on the ninth floor
of the Metropole Hotel,
the Chinese doctor infected 13
other people from around the world.
Two days after he checked in,
the disease was in Hanoi.
Three days after that,
it crossed the Pacific to Toronto.
Two days after that, it entered Singapore.
In other words,
the disease was a global epidemic before
anybody realized it was a global epidemic.
In fact, it was a global epidemic
before it even had a name.
Today, we know this disease as
Severe Acute Respiratory Syndrome, or SARS.
So the bad news is that globalization
means that diseases travel
fast in the 21 Century.
But there are so many zombie movies out
there, on such widely varying topics as
Abraham Lincoln killing zombies, or
zombie beavers, that I hope
you all ready know that.
In the bottom middle, there was
even a SARS inspired zombie movie
that was based on "Star Wars" and
called -- believe it or not -- "SARS Wars".
That's the bad news. The good news is
that we have a lot more weapons against
epidemics in the 21st
Century as well.
Researchers quickly realized they
were dealing with the special
type of virus called a coronavirus when
they looked at SARS under a microscope.
Why is it called a coronavirus?
Because when you look at
it under the microscope,
it looks like the sun's
corona during an eclipse.
Now, coronaviruses, like HIV and
influenza are RNA viruses,
which mean that they possess RNA not DNA.
In 2003, researchers quickly
sequenced the SARS coronavirus,
which makes up a genome
with 29,751 nucleotides.
Here's a short snippet from
the end of this RNA genome.
Now, RNA replication has a much
higher error rate than DNA,
which means that RNA viruses
are able to mutate fast.
This is why the flu shot changes from year
to year, and it's also why there are so
many different types of HIV and
why we don't have a vaccine for HIV either.
It's very difficult to vaccinate against
something that can mutate so quickly.
Here we see it's mutated in just
in the time I'm talking to you.
Now, research initially
thought that like HIV and
influenza, SARS had jumped
from animals to humans.
They first blamed birds, because of
the similarity of SARS with bird flu,
a form of influenza that
originated in chickens and
first crossed the species
barrier to humans in 1997.
But which animal did give us SARS?
How was it that we came to be
infected in the first place?
And how can we reconstruct its path
that it traveled around the world?
It may not seem like it immediately, but
all of these questions are related to
constructing evolutionary trees, which
are also commonly called phylogenies.
For example,
here's the first evolutionary tree,
which was drawn by Charles Darwin in 1837.
And here's a phylogeny that's
constructed for HIV and its relatives.
Just from this evolutionary tree,
we can infer that HIV crossed the species
barrier from monkeys to humans at five
different places, marked by stars.
These five different crossings divide
HIV into five different viral families.
Now, from this HIV diagram,
it should be clear that if we want to
know which animal gave us SARS, we should
just construct an evolutionary tree for
the SARS coronavirus as well as
coronaviruses from other species.
Then, we simply see where SARS is located
in this tree with respect to other
coronaviruses.
But the question remains though,
what algorithms do we need to use in
order to construct evolutionary trees?